we still don't have a flash movie but we
have a movie now that's like the flash
if the flash was a snail pretty much
turbo yeah we registered about gasps Oh
turbo is the story of a snail who's a
slow snail like any other snails he has
hopes and dreams and he watches the Indy
500 on his TV and he's like I want to
race like those guys but he's a snail so
he can only go at a snail's pace why the
term exists one day he gets sucked into
a fast and furious car right when the
Nos goes through the engine and instead
of being vaporized and killed he's
turned into a super fast now known as
turbo high register America I'll say
this about the movie the movie is cute
it's like good for kids I don't know
about you but I see a lot of movies so
in a movie like this I'm like I think I
know how this movie's gonna go down here
it is for you this is a movie about a
snail that gets really fast it wants to
race in the Indy 500 and he gets the
opportunity to how do you think this
movie's gonna play out spoiler alert it
plays out just like that and it's kind
of a bummer it makes you feel like
they're just phoning it in it's like
someone was like we need a really quick
kids movie to come out in the same
weekend as the conjuring I slapped that
together that's good here's a snail with
superpowers I mean the voice acting is
really good Ryan Reynolds plays turbo
Paul Giamatti plays his brother T
embodies an awesome actress one of the
best actors out there he's got a bunch
of little side character snails among
them samuel l.jackson snoop one of the
cool aspects of the movie is that there
are these humans that turbo and his
brother come across voiced by Michael
Pena Luis guzmán and they're ultimately
they're the parallels they're the mirror
image of turbo and his brother Michael
Pena when he's like I want hopes and
dreams and Luis Guzman is like no I
don't do that that's for cool people
like Paul Giamatti saying to turbo weird
thing was though this might be the magic
of Michael Pena cuz I'm a fan of that
dude at this point when he came into the
movie it's like the movie made him the
star of it not turbo you were more
invested in his hopes and dreams and his
problems and the fact that he wanted to
succeed this you know he kind of pairs
up with turbo and it might have been
aided in the fact that when the movies
concentrating on him and he's talking to
turbo turbo doesn't talk because turbos
a snail if you talked to him that
wouldn't make any sense he's a human
he's a snail snails and human to humans
can't hear snails talk the movie is
called turbo but it shouldn't be really
it should be called that dude who were
in the taco stands I'll say this though
it was really cool to see turbo go
really fast but he's just burning rubber
anywhere you're like you can't help but
smile you're like oh that's cool hopes
and dreams coming true and [ __ ] the last
half-hour of this movie when it really
gets down to the racing metaphorically
speaking the climax of most any movie is
a race to success so when the race to
success is an actual race in a movie I'm
always like that I'm locked in I find
this really entertaining I guess I like
races and movies watching the actual
Indy 500 pretty boring make it all
cinematic I am there with you
turbo isn't close to my favorite
animation of the year but it is what it
is a bit forgettable pretty generic but
fun for kids I will say turbo is a good
time no alcohol required if you're a kid
which makes it that statement does make
sense there are parts of the world where
kids can drink where kids are referred
to as soldiers number kids you booze you
lose they're better there are a lot of
movies coming out this weekend what
movie are you looking forward to the
most whatever it is comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you